nature is full of organisms that
iridescent wild displays of structural
color and some can even control it
themselves while dyes and pigments
produce color by selectively absorbing
light structural colors are produced
when light interacts with the
microscopic structure of a material
inspired by an organism that uses
structural color the chameleon
researchers have created a bio hybrid a
color-changing gel embedded with living
heart cells that can display and control
structural color on its own their method
involves placing heart muscle cells
cardiomyocytes onto biocompatible gels
with structural color properties the
gels were made by arranging silica
nanoparticles on a glass slide and
covering them with a specialized gelatin
this gel was then peeled off leaving
imprints of tiny pores from the
nanoparticles some wavelengths of light
disappeared down into the pores while
others were reflected creating vivid
colors when the hard cells swell and
contract the gel does the same resulting
in a shift in its structural color in
synchrony with the pulsing of the cells
by placing cells into tiny patterned
grooves in the gel the team was able to
create a material that mimics a tiny
butterfly flapping its wings as the
cells expand and contract the wings move
displaying a changing structural color
the team also showed that the bio-hybrid
gels could be combined with other
materials to mimic the functions of the
heart as a virtual heart on a chip such
a device could be used for biomedical
testing instead of using human or animal
organs they tested the heart on a chip
by adding various concentrations of a
drug which is known to change the heart
rate different concentrations of the
drug made the heart cells beat at
different frequencies and produce shifts
in the structural color of the gel this
platform can make it easier to monitor
the effects of drugs and testing
using only the naked
[Music]